so of course the whole of season five
has been leading for Cersei towards this
culmination of her comeuppance in this
walk of shame that people seen what is
your feelings about that particular
moment for her character it's these are
this is one of the storylines that
people have given have committed a lot
of their imagination to I think everyone
that I talked to who describes the walk
of the walk of shame has has said to me
that they have always depicted a very a
certain scenario happening the way that
it happens whether she's dragged or
whether she is pushed or whether she
there are rocks being thrown or whether
they take they they quite accurately
depict what they see and I think that
it'll capture the imagination of a lot
enough a lot of our our viewers because
this is one of the characters that has
had such a such a role based on the
struggle to maintain power and how how
how her fall is depicted I think is
going to be a huge credit to why the
quality of Game of Thrones keeps it the
state stays so high how it looks when
you're there compared to how one how one
experiences on your television are two
very different things and therefore even
for me it's exciting to think of what
they could have done in the editing room
to create the walk of shame so I'm
excited I think episode 10 was the kind
of the through ition of loads of
storylines I was I was pretty had to say
even though we get a lot of the scripts
I was pretty shocked by the way that
they put it together they they never
they never missed a beat
I was I've been pretty I've been pretty
intrigued by the story of the the
Tyrells so far particularly as they're
this family who were so close to to
getting some degree of political power
and rather like Cersei the carpet has
been swept beneath their feet it it's
it's a pretty shocking pretty shocking a
pretty extraordinary ending so I'm
excited I'm excited to see what Dan
David Bryan and the team are going to
come up with for season six what are the
chances we'll see you back the season
six and what would you like your
character to do if you are back I have I
don't know what the chances are we're
gonna go with 50/50 for now let's hope
that let's hope that he's going to come
back if he does come back well the one
thing the one thing I would say that I'm
not afraid of is dying
I have no
fair that if he's gonna die is gonna die
and they've chosen that a long time ago
I hope he goes well I hope he goes dying
and dies fighting fighting to the bitter
end for his cause but I I'm looking
forward to I'm looking I'm looking
forward to the writing primarily I'm
looking forward to what they will do
with the storyline that is now got it
going into unknown territory and I I've
always really enjoyed how they have
taken the storyline how they have
deviated their own ways from George's
original storyline I think they've done
it with tremendous sort of commitment
and yet at the same time sort of bravery
and they've taken some really big steps
to show you parts of characters that you
wouldn't have to get gotten the chance
to see in George's books to create kind
of new new emotional reactions from
characters such as Breen and hound and I
think it's wonderful what they're doing
so I'm looking forward to seeing what
they do
you